- Senator Lindsay Graham
has authored a bill to
ban abortions nationwide
15 weeks after conception,
with very few exceptions.
- And that is a little more liberal
than what the Europeans do.
- Now, many have compared
this to European countries
where generally there is
a minimum of 15 weeks,
but there's also lots
and lots of exceptions.
- Should we look like Iran and North Korea
when it comes to national abortion policy?
Or maybe France, Belgium, Germany, Spain,
Denmark and Norway?
- And, of course, many European
countries allow abortion
after 15 weeks, not needing an exception.
Many have criticized this potential law
as hypocritical, given the
language around states' rights.
This would, of course,
ban abortion nationwide
and take it out of the state's hands.
- This is where America should
be at the federal level.
- And as we've covered
on this channel before
given the valence of the
current Supreme Court,
many people are worried that
a national ban would be held
up as constitutional by the Supreme Court,
but a national right to abortion
would not be considered constitutional,
given the political leanings
of the current justices.